we'll we'll start it off formally and
then we can just talk um all right going
to start off with the pledge
representative love you're here today
why don't you join us why don't you Leen
The
Pledge to the flag of the United States
of America and to the Republic for which
it stands nation under God indivisible
with liy and justice for
all okay
we just assuming that we're GNA be doing
a lot of voting can you help me figure
out yeah and just do myself a favor and
just call me first so I know I usually
go last just call me first it'll be
easier that way um GNA pull up hold on
let me pull up the schedule here um okay
so let's uh here so here here here's the
game plan uh we're probably going to
meet two more time uh one more time
after this um so anything we don't like
finish finish today uh we've got a
non-gain Amendment um which I did
schedule for next week and then I was
kindly instructed to not schedule things
during school vacation week uh so we're
going to go the week after um there's
going to be a non Amendment from
representative walner uh we have to so
non we have to do a hearing um so what
we'll do is we'll do the hearing and
exec on the same day for that bill so we
have to meet one more time uh regard L
um so anything that we don't come to
consensus today we'll do in two weeks
and that will probably be the finality
of uh our work um assuming we don't get
anything from the Senate um we might
which we might very well do so um that's
kind of the game plan so today I'm
thinking will'll be very short
um and if I can bring up my schedule
here um because I want to start with the
um
here we
go I want to start with the ratios
because representative walner has
an session on House Bill uh
1407 relative to child care Staffing
ratios um I will make the motion of
ought to pass is there a
second uh representative Sweeney makes a
second is there a um
is there an amendment anyone would like
to take up representative walner has an
amendment representative walner would
you please distribute the amendment then
we'll make a motion of to discuss your
Amendment and we'll get a second on that
we'll be on discussion on the
amendment yeah
anybody absolutely
absolutely okay so let's uh let's have
some formality here uh representative
walner I assume that you're making a
motion of ought to pass uh to adopt
Amendment 2024 H
07538 all right so moved is there a
second for representative wner
representative McWilliams seconds the
motion we are now on discussion of the
amendment representative wner would you
like to speak to your Amendment yes I
brought the amendment in and talked to
um our chairman about it last week
um
I I really brought it in for us to talk
about in case there's ways that people
think that they need to change it in
some way we may need to take a look at
this to be sure that it works um the
original bill is about changing the
ratios in child care allowing an extra
child when there are two providers with
um infants and
toddlers And what I did was um
Turn part of this into a waiver system
so that if you decide at your child care
facility that you would like to do this
add the extra child then you would apply
to the state to the uh Licensing Bureau
for a waiver to allow you to um have the
extra child
um the waiver is down I think you can if
you go to uh line 25 say section
4 um it talks about the waiver and how
it would work the department would
um promate rules around any
refusal uh for waivers um and there
would not be any limit on the number of
waivers so if there are 700 childcare
providers in the state there would not
be a limit on the number they couldn't
say we only going to give a 100 waivers
they would have to it would have to be
open to every child care provider to
apply and um that there could be no fee
for the application of a waiver if you
or the
renewal
um it calls for in section five it calls
for the Department to
report twice during this period um about
the number of waivers the number of
waiver denials there were so that we
would have some information about how it
was working and um whether people were
using it what kinds of things the
department was finding um as the process
went on and the waiver process and ends
and sunsets in uh November 1 no December
31st of
2026 okay are questions uh further
statements questions on the way on the
amendment yes represented MC Williams uh
thank you so much chair Barry um so I I
think that this is a reasonable approach
without having a study committee and the
whole study process to look at this
because I know we're in a childcare
emergency um I think that doing this as
sort of a pilot with a an end date
allows us to collect the same data that
we may be able to collect by doing a
study but actually handson with real
life examples of how it's working
um and I really like this because I
think that this is a potential uh
Revenue stream for facilities that
already have the demand for one more um
infant or toddler and so they could free
up and have that space and get the
additional uh tuition for the infant or
toddler without having to hire more
staff so IT addresses that desire to be
able to flex and take more kids that are
on waiting lists right now um without
making it um you know a a permanent
thing because we're not really sure
about the data so I like this because I
see this as an interim step to getting
to something permanent without diving
right off the deep end um and I and so
the centr interest in me thinks that
this is a really nice clean approach um
to to get the data further questions
comments on the amendment um okay I'll
give mine um I agree and I want to thank
uh representative walner for working
with me on this as you guys know this is
kind of the thing that um was my
immediate solution or at least first
thought Solution on this um and I
believe this was done in good faith um I
am totally fine with the auto repal
after 2 years um and the reason I'm
totally fine with the auto repeal after
two years is if I am wrong we can it
goes away and if I'm right there will be
a push to keep it um so I'm totally I'm
totally fine to pick up the dice and
roll them because I feel like they're
going to land my way um you know it
could come up seven you never know but
uh I'm totally fine with this uh I think
I think it actually does strike a very
cous approach right and I appreciate
representative walner addressing my
concerns about not limiting the number
of people that can apply not limiting
the number of people that can be taken
um I think it does give the department
the flexibility if they see something
that maybe a center is not operating at
this level appropriately or there's a
long history of safety violations and
they go hey look you can barely handle
four you really won't be able to handle
four and a half um you know um I think
that's actually very reasonable so I do
appreciate the good faith effort on it
um I look forward to voting for the
amendment and then hopefully the passage
of the underlying
Bill any other further comments
questions
concerns okay uh seeing none the clerk
will call the role on the motion to
adopt Amendment
2024-25
3H um and then we'll have another motion
for R to pass this
amended I assume I
assume representative Barry the chair
votes
yes um
representative speedi
yes representative n
yes representative love
yes representative walner
yes representative cran votes yes
representative M yes
representative chki
yes representative each
yes that is n y and zero
and missing nail biter um okay uh we now
need a new motion for a to pass as
amended I'll be happy to make the motion
of a to pass as amended on House Bill
1407 with Amendment 202 24-0 753h is
there a
second representative Wallner seconds is
there discussion on the bill as
amended seeing n when Madam clerk is
ready the clerk well no we we've already
in the voting mode so when Clerk's ready
technically I haven't called it but when
Madam clerk is ready the clerk will call
the
role chair the chair votes
yes representative Sweeney yes
representative n yes representative love
yes representative walner yes clerk
votes yes representative MC Williams yes
representative tki yes representative H
yes 9 Z all right with that um the
motion of op to pass as amended on House
Bill 1407 carries on a vote of 9 to Z um
I there's any represent want don't you
have any objection if I handle the
committee report would you like to
handle it I I they I usually people
don't don't fight to do the committee
report so I will handle I'm happy to
handle the committee report on
1407 um the only other Mega piece of
business that we need to do is oh oh yes
is there a motion for consent calendar
can I see a motion for consent a second
Noe without objection excellent all
right we'll put that bad boy on consent
um next up we'll do um uh we'll open
I'll close the executive session on
House Bill 1407 and open the executive
session on um House
Bill 1 1056 excuse me 10 1056 the
dyslexia kicked in there a little bit I
apologize because I believe
representative wner has an amendment
correct I do isn't this this is nerain
so you're going to introduce it and then
we're going to recess
yeah yep yeah just hand it out and then
we'll you make the motion to adopt the
amendment somebody will second it I'll
say it's non- gerain and then we'll
notice the public hearing for the non-
gerain amendment in two weeks and do the
same day exact just to keep things
formal uh then we have then I'll and
then I will magically recess the
committee
okay so uh representative walner is
moving Amendment 2024
-76 H to House Bill
1056 uh I will second her motion and I
will now rule the amendment non gerain I
will schedule a non- derain hearing for
two weeks um and we will exec the bill
so so you guys be noticed we will do the
non- gerain hearing and then we will
exec the bill so it'll be a same day
exec uh and with that I will recess the
executive session on House Bill 15 10 0
1056 wow can you tell I am not awake yet
um yeah the problem is I I had my
physical today so I I didn't get to have
I didn't get to have I actually had to
go in and get my physical so I could
have my letter saying I'm fit to work
with children um so I haven't had my
coffee yet yes representative MC
Williams um thank you chair Barry just
for scheduling purposes do you have a
date and time are we doing Wednesday 6
10 a.m. it yes it I Tred to actually
schedule it for next week and then I was
corre uh instructed not to do that so it
will be the 6th at 10: a.m. perfect
thank you um yes okay so now the only
thing we have left are bills that I
imagine will be uh the same will all be
voting the same way be my guess um that
being said I'll do I'll make the same
kind of pitch I made last year if you
recall where if there is something you
want to work on
um now is the time to
identify a bill to do so um sorry I'm
trying to pull it up here we
go so uh if you see if you have an idea
Now's the Time to throw it out there but
we'll start it off with
um uh I'll open up the house executive
session on house on the committee
executive session on House Bill 1405
relative to limiting the publication of
child care
violations um I'll start it off with
making a motion of inexpedient to
legislate is there a second representive
wner seconds um so uh I love this bill
it's my bill it came to us via our
friend Kora she had an experience um
where her insurance rates were doubled
because of the insurance company went
and pulled the rochest I believe they
serve what is 150 children something
like that uh they serve a lot in
Rochester um and her insurance rates
doubled because of the insurance company
going and pulling uh the
report uh the violations report um and I
never looked at her VI for the full
disclosure I never looked at her
violations report I'm taking on her word
she said there wasn't there wasn't
safety violations in
there take her word on it um I can't I
didn't I didn't I didn't trust but
verify um so I I think what I want to
say on this is I think there's more work
to be done in this space I think the
department needs to take a healthy look
at how they're doing violations um these
things are real um but that being said
we did hear this would endanger the
scholarship fund um and as much as I
enjoy telling the feds where to go um
it's not the juice is not worth the
squeeze to endanger the fund for this so
uh that's why I'm making an iil motion
on my own bill but I do kind of want to
have that said
of
a a future solution to this problem
would be awesome um this unfortunately
is not it so um with that are there
further discussions on the bill rest MC
Williams thank you chair Barry just to
comment that this special committee can
and has the ability to create a working
subcommittee on specific issues and this
may be one that is worthwhile yeah it
totally is and like I said I I would I
would re I would I would have made the
motion for is if I believed in is um but
I don't um but I'm definitely down if we
want to meet and discuss it for the next
legislature to figure something out um
it this just in my opinion once again
I'm the sponsor uh it just wasn't it so
uh further yes represent mean um I'll
just add we did hear from the Department
that they were in contact with um the
insurance commissioner and trying to
work some things out um that way and
felt that those discussions were were
being fruitful so hopefully we'll get
some action on that even without our our
committee meeting if it could be solved
without legislation even
better okay um any other
comments questions concerns okay with
that the clerk will call the role for
the motion of inexpedient to legislate
on House Bill uh
10405 FN wow do you still want me to
call you uh yeah it's fine I mean I made
the
motion chair votes
yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative n representative love
representative sorry for me too
representative wner
yes CL votes yes representative McAn yes
representative tki yes representative
Peach yes
zero okay um and the last one we'll do
um today and I'll I'll punt 1584 so you
know till two weeks from now um the last
one we'll do today is uh we close the
exec sorry let me go through this here
House Bill uh
15 uh House Bill 1405 FN will be
reported as any speed legisl on a vote
of 10 to zero is there a motion for
consent
calendar so moved without objection
1405 will be placed on the consent
calendar I'll close the executive
session on House Bill 14 5 and open the
exe uh I'll take care of it I mean I've
killed my own bill
so um are you sure you're taking on a
lot I if you want to write it I will
never object I will never object if
someone who wants to write a report it
won't not bother me at all um you'll
have far less typos and it'll be
coherent so be much
better
um with the and the clerk the clerk will
appreciate
it uh we'll open up that close the
executive session of 405 I'm going to
open the execution T from 1409 uh
relative to review by The Advisory
Council on child care of child care
center violations um uh I'll make a
motion of inexpedient to legislate on
this um but is there a
second second uh I would love to discuss
it just so you know um and because I do
think you know this bill is not ready
for prime time I knew that when I
submitted it nobody seemed to really
want to work on it other than me um that
being said I do think there needs to be
some sort of a Jud
uh uh appeals process that doesn't go
through the same judge jury and
executioner um and you know if we wanted
to take another hack at this I'm happy
to pull back the itl motion and we can
take another hack at it but um nobody
approached me on it so I put in the
child care advisory committee um without
asking
them um because they were the most
logical body to go to um so you know
it's just one of those deals during LSR
filing I was like well I hope they like
this maybe they won't who knows um but I
there is a legitimate concern I think
with
DHHS making a finding you appeal that
finding to
that uh licensers supervisor who then is
let's be honest probably predisposed to
backup their licenser they're going to
refute that statement but we all live in
reality and we know that's the truth um
and then after that you kind of exhaust
your options and then you might have to
go to court um which no childcare
Center's going to do they're just going
to be like all right take it and move on
um but I do hear about in my
conversations with owners there's like a
legitimate I wouldn't say legi maybe
there's a there's a real we heard about
it in our public our public listening
session in Manchester um when we
actually had the most owners operators
show up that was the one where we had
the most operators show up um and the
reason we had the most operators there
was because I invited 330 of them
um there is when I talk to childcare
workers who are in management or owners
they fear the department there's they
fear them they they tell me they're
scared um and this was my thought
process solution of well here's a way to
make the boogeyman not so bad um you'll
have you can go in front of somebody who
is like you uh and they can determine if
it was legitimate um doesn't mean by the
way you're going to get off um it just
means that you have in a process that's
outside of the judge jury and
executioner um that's not a condemnation
of DHHS that's not they're the bad
people they're the bad guys I'm not
saying that I'm just saying the
perception is reality and that's how
they perceive it um I'll speak from
personal um experience having the
government come into your business is
very invasive I get it I'm not saying
DHHS should shouldn't inspect in fact I
think there was a survey I want to say
was it last week that they that's one of
the advocacy groups sent out about DHHS
is proposing a rule right right now they
do one unsupervised one unannounced
visit a year and they're going to
they're talking about moving to a system
of one announced visit um and one
unannounced visit the announced visit
being for the purposes of of uh
paperwork compliance um so you guys know
I voted against it just because I was
like you're just coming in one more time
uh but I totally actually appreciate D
hhs's idea there of hey we're going to
come and look at paperwork on this dat
and then we're going to come by and do
our random on the other date um so I
think that that I think that that will
be helpful I just could in good faith
vote to have the government come in like
guaranteed one more time um even though
I know they're already doing it twice um
but I I think that this committee needs
to and maybe it's something else that we
can do a working group on and study
because you actually public hearing I
didn't even realize this the Realtors
kind of have some
self-regulation um obviously real
estate's a lot different than childcare
but uh I do think that with the
legislator would be wise to if not now
but in the future find something that
addresses this concern from operators um
at a minimum just to let's call it
increase a level of perceived fairness
um so that'll be my monologue on this
subject I'm happy to hear from anyone
else uh representative wner so I think
that we heard
um that right now as the rules are the
childcare rules are being looked at and
uh worked on that this is something that
they are considering within the rules so
I think before we pass any sort of law
it might be good to see what happens in
the rules and maybe have them come back
and tell us exactly how they you know
how the new rules address this issue
yeah I I think that would be good um and
I I'll Circle up with DHHS afterwards
and figure out where we are and I know
they're approaching the finality of that
process um and we've said before for
are Subs uh basically DHHS in the
process of going through all of the
child care rules right now um and
producing a more streamlined version of
it and I'm very very thankful that they
are doing that um so but anyways so we
we'll Circle back on this we're going to
iil this bill right now uh wait for the
rules U or at least I'm going to vote
for iil what you do is your business but
uh but I think that needs to be said I
think the department should hear that um
because like I'll say it but you know
your average operator your average
director won't have the courage to say
it but they'll say it they won't say it
to you but they'll say it to me um and
they're not wrong so with that the cler
sorry represent MC Williams I apologize
that's okay I'll be very brief um I
agree with everything that you've said
and this Echoes exactly the testimony we
received when we did a study on the
success of the business of child care
about six years ago um do you think that
the board of realtors is a good model
for um an internal review uh there are
other
uh groups that have something similar um
so I think that uh perhaps having a
presentation by DHHS uh as part of one
of our upcoming meetings would be
helpful perhaps when after crossover uh
we could ask for that presentation on an
update uh and I also think that um we
could ask for some research on what
other agencies do for appeals from our
uh researcher I think that's actually a
great idea yeah so I don't want to give
up on this bill I understand the itl
motion but I I completely champion this
having an appeal that's outside of judge
jury and executioner so do you want to
do you want to pull it back and we just
sit on it for a minute or do you want to
kill it I I don't want to kill it I want
to fight for it um I I I would rather
interim study but you don't do interim
study uh I think that this is the sort
of thing we want to keep alive so that
it's top of mind um and certainly keep
on the list of things that we are
studying as a committee whether or not
there's a Bill assigned to it it's nice
to have an empty vehicle to shove some
stuff in at the last minute um this
might be one of those things we hang on
to so if we were to not execute today
that would not be such a bad thing uh
but also I think that there really are
legs and there's something going on here
that I don't want to give up on today I
don't I don't we'll have we'll hear from
representative creation and then I
will'll see what your ranking member
says because she I don't know if she
fully agrees but that's okay sure um
again just looking back at the minutes
from the last meeting um Melissa Clement
said uh they're already looking at doing
something like this modeling it after
their adult process and that the child
care advisory panel is helping them seat
the panel um but not be the panel um and
so they they all seem to agree that we
don't need anything in statute um right
now I I don't have very strong feelings
on keeping an empty vehicle alive I
guess but just wanted to just wanted to
make sure that I read iterated what was
said representative representative
wner well just to say what I said before
what I'd like to do is I I would like to
just itl the bill at this point let the
department and the child care advisory
committee um work through a proposal
that they're going to put in they're
going to suggest for rules and then have
them come in and describe to us how
they're going to move forward um with
this idea and um
then if doesn't seem like it's something
that's workable we might bring in
legislation for um next year
I I think what I'm going to do I think
I'm changing my mind I'm going to what
I'm going to do is I'm going to recess
this bill I I uh I I appreciate the
ranking member I like the idea if if
there's going to be genuine work on it I
like the idea of keeping a vehicle out
there um
because I don't if we don't
have if I was to predict the future I
would I predict I'm going to regret
doing this and I'm gonna have to come
back in two months and I all the bill so
let me just start off with I believe
that that's where it's going to go that
being
said if DHHS is almost done and we see
something that needs to be changed this
gives us an option um so I think what
I'm going to do is I'm going to recess
the bill and we'll leave the vehicle
alive I understand we're going to
probably itl It Anyways um but I like
the idea of having something there in
case the HHS finds something that they
say hey we actually need to change this
um or the advisory Council comes forward
and says hey uh this is how we want this
is how we want this to look and DHHS
doesn't agree and we can go okay well we
agree so we move forward um so I'm going
to recess that I'm going to recess the
bill we we' never entered the voting
mode so when we when we come back from
recess we will be on an itl motion just
so you guys know know the the the the
stance of the committee will be on an
itl motion um but we won't uh we won't
do it today um and maybe we'll come back
in two we can handle in two weeks if we
Circle up and talk privately and and
decide we're not going we can we're
meeting in two weeks anyway so it's it's
it doesn't matter um all right and then
I'll open uh I'll open up I'll close the
I'm obviously I just recessed the
executive SE session
um for uh 1409 I'll open up the
executive session for 1584 and I'll
recess that to um and that'll be the
conclusion of our business for today uh
we are going to meet again in two weeks
uh for the non- gerain uh Bill the non
gerain hearing excuse me and then we'll
have the three other the three other
votes if we haven't had any forward
progress on anything else um and I I
said I always knew today was going to be
short and I appreciate the committee's
diligence um I will Circle up so I have
got a couple things in my notes here I'm
going to ask our researcher for um how
like the Realtors handle this and some
other third
parties um uh I'll Circle up sorry yes
can you ask them um how the adult or how
DHHS does it for their adult systems
that what they told us they wereing okay
absolutely adult systems
um and we'll uh and I'll Circle up with
I'll Circ up with DHHS actually next
thing I like how do they handle that so
you actually beat me to the next thing I
was going to say so perfect all right so
we we'll make some work for our
wonderful researcher Christina if you've
never met her she is wonderful um she
has to deal with me in election law and
here so God bless her um and with that
I'm going to close our executive session
thank you guys I'll see you in two I'll
see you on Thursday but I'll see you
tomorrow and I'll see you in two weeks
thank you
guys